bonsoir
rien ne semble vous atteindre si vous
êtes je sais pas vous êtes encore plus
jolie qu'il ya trois ans quand on sait
comme cela ça fait plaisir c'est vrai
qu'ils aient pas beaucoup de plaisir non
partant là on est comment vous faites le
splendide je crois que le combat me
renforce et boghni tonus depuis quatre
ans j'ai rajeuni la fille qu'on s'est
vus merci oui c'est vrai de très
séduisante là c'est pourquoi tu veux te
la faire quoi non c'est sincère c'est
vrai je te reste combien vachement vous
êtes très très svelte et à des moyens
c'est-à-dire qu'ils gagnent des roues
oui ça va lui falloir des sceaux bien
vous connaissez christophe bien sûr
ah oui ça va venir ouais ça m à m pas
plus bardon bien
alors on va commencer par l'autre actu
parce qu'on vous avait invité en fait
pour votre bouquin avant de savoir ce
qui allait se passer cette semaine
mercredi dernier donc le tribunal
correctionnel de paris dans le cadre de
l' affaire elf pour recel d'abus de
biens sociaux a condamné roland dumas à
30 mois de prison dont six ferme et 1
million de francs d'amendé loïk le floch
prigent trois ans et demi de prison
ferme et 2 millions de francs d'amendé
si revel 4 ans et 2 millions de francs
et vous trois ans de prison dont 18 mois
ferme et amie enceinte d'amande vous
regrettez pas d'avoir rendu le pognon
parce que là pour payer l'amendé aurait
été bien je ne regrette pas non toujours
dire la vérité ou d'affaires qu'on a
quand même la bouilloire avait rendu le
pognon et ça les a pas rendu plus
clément ont déjà même façon non mais
c'est c'était attendu
moi je n'ai juste tout le monde appelle
en lisant mon dieu mais comment tu
prends ça mais je le prends d'une façon
tout à fait naturelle
est ce que j'ai toujours dit et vous
m'avez reçu ici plusieurs fois vous a
reçu pour la première version
après l'opération bravo aux opérations
la première est déjà opération travaux
je l'avais écrit justement c'est un
combat pour dire si je suis jugé sans qu
on ouvre le dossier du marché des
frégates à taïwan
je ne peux pas être jugés équitablement
on a essayé de sortir le dossier des
frégates j'ai écrit des livres je suis
allé à taïwan j'ai pris aussi beaucoup
de risques on n'a toujours pas pu ouvrir
le dossier des frégates à taïwan
donc on ne peut pas me juger on a le
corps on n'a pas la tête c'est à dire
que l'argent qu'on me reproche
il est justement dans 16 mois
puisqu'en même temps de f et thomson je
travaille pour les 2 e et aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas me condamner on ne sait pas
l'argent on n'a pas expliqué pourquoi
puisque le dossier des frégates était
encore en balance
donc c'était attendu je ne suis pas
étonné voilà donc l'argent que vous avez
reçue c'est de l'argent qui vous était
donné pour les frégates pour convaincre
entendu man comme d'accepter que les
frégates
le dossier était commissionné pour le
roi d'ys à quel montant
une émission sur deux on est où là non
dans celle du helmand puisque si on est
là c'est le sont plus depuis bien 99
depuis l'opération mois et puis un petit
peu avant j'ai menti ne période où je
protège et un homme j'ai menti pendant
le temps qu'il a fallu que j'estimais
devoir protéger cet homme il ya eu des
déceptions bon si on ne va pas revenir
sur tout ce passé et un jour je ne
pouvais plus je suis allé voir les juges
et j'ai dit voilà
et bien maintenant j'en peux plus porter
tout ça je viens je viens de dire la
vérité et en donne disant la vérité j'ai
rendu 22 millions et savez les gazelles
parce que parce que je le vis mieux
aussi bien là d'autres plans qui est
commun est ce que vous faites appel ou
pas on sait pas encore mon nom mon
avocat de société - n'a pas encore pris
la décision parce que dumas il fait
appel lui tout son appel tous font appel
alors si vous faites appel dès qu'elle
même verdict devant prison alors si je
fais appel oui j'ai trois mois de prison
ferme
vous penserez à moi ouais vous apportera
des enjeux maintenance connaît on a
droit à des visites non oui il faut que
vous demander au juge je pense que vous
aurez parce que par voie sexuelle maman
les prisons help en france en espagne un
bon mais il faudrait que ça vienne en
venir à toi à moi je vais jusqu'à 6
heures
c'était génial c'est génial
non c'est pas totalement libre il ya une
petite bille il fait justement c'est ça
qui est excitant et laure sirven j'étais
un peu déçu parce que quand vous le
sylvain n'y va venir il va dire la
vérité moi mon alfred de mon alfred et
les idées rien d c'est fou hein
dans tout ça les hommes où ils m'ont
twist aise en faites pas je veux pas me
lancer des fleurs mais la seule qui
parle qui dit la vérité c'est moi votre
employeur a pas dit elle a travaillé ils
veulent pas ya que moi qui ai dit si tu
suis malade je suis pas déçu par les
hommes je crois que je suis tombé aussi
dans une catégorie d'hommes un peu
particulier c'est une affaire d'état tri
c'est pas une petite affaire n'ont
peut-être que si sirvin aujourd'hui a
décidé de pas parler c'est qu'il a ses
raisons est que c'est grave aussi de
faire tomber toute une classe politique
c'est la république est en danger c'est
la cinquième
j'ai toujours dit qu'elle était en
danger peut-être qu'alfred a jugé bon de
ne pas la faire tomber
la fiche 69 les rôles sont inversés que
les signes de viège en cours et c'est
vous qui me poser une question ou là ça
se fait ça ouais vous acceptez tout tout
aulas
vous savez quand on m'a traitée de
[ __ ] de la république est ce que vous
aimeriez qu'on vous traite [ __ ] de
l'audimat
non voilà c'est très bien tout est là
avec vous en était le titre de votre
premier livre des juges qui m'ont traité
comme ça dans un livre j'ai pris ce
titre parce qu'il fallait que je
reconnus par ironie pour j'ai montré que
j'étais pas cette cité commerciale par
titre vous auriez pu avoir mon portable
à neutre et pourtant pipeau
en plus d'eux en plus de l fait des
frégates maintenant est revenue souvent
dernièrement dans la presse au sujet des
révélations du général aussaresses alors
j'explique à nos amis qui sont pas tous
au courant le général aussaresses les
clarisses appel aux services spéciaux
algérie 55 57
il raconte l'époque de la répression
contre les nationalistes algériens et en
particulier durant la bataille d'alger
alors il reconnaît dans ce bouquin
général français qui est retourné dans
ce bouquin en fait tuer des dizaines de
prisonniers et il confirme la torture
par l'électricité et l'or selon le jdd
journal du dimanche et le figaro c'est à
cause de la fascination que vous exercez
sur lui et pour vous impressionner que
ce vieux général a craché le morceau dès
qu'il ya un dieu façon dès qu'il ya un
vieux os écrit faut dire non j'ai
rencontré ce général aussaresses
justement à l'époque où j'écrivais
opération bravo vous rappeler que dans
l'opération bravo si vous avez encore la
mémoire il y avait tout un marché
tout un chapitre sur le marché
d'armement en france qui était quand
même
atradius gratte et bien sûr il a fallu
que je fasse un travail d'investigation
comme comme des journalistes le fond et
j'ai été présenté lors d'un déjeuner à
ce général aussaresses qui m'a dit avoir
été consultant pour l'armement chez
thomson j'aime dit l'aubaine il va m'en
dire des choses et j'essayais en même
temps de se voir pour les frégates mon
avocate et moi nous avions envisagé de
le faire
venir comme témoin pendant le procès
pour justement parler de ça puis
quelques mois avant a explosé cette
cette histoire d'algérie dans la foulée
il a écrit son livre moi il me disait
écrire ses mémoires qui s'appelait chef
de bande sur l'indochine la résistance
qui était formidable
et puis la faire de l'algérie nous a un
petit peu fait peur donc on a renoncé à
voir le général aussaresses comme témoin
d'accord cet homme ment j'ai rien contre
lui il m'a quand même protégé et c'est
lui qui avait dénoncé le contrat qui
avait eu sur ma vie qui m'avait fait fin
gilet pare balles pendant que j'écrivais
opération bravo donc je lui dois
mais c'est moi qui vous a prêté un jeune
baba yetu quatre pattes dans une petite
pièce bien sûr cet homme j'ai rien
contre lui alors aujourd'hui on dit
qu'il a flashé pour moi tu es là lâche
qu'il agit l'âge que j'ai c'est attendez
je comprends très bien qu'il ait fait
découvrir
je vais dire faut arrêter je l ça a été
moins thomson sa et et moi j'ai quand
même pas avancer la guerre d'algérie
mais vous les photos sa charge alors il
ya une autre actualité sur vous c'est
votre c'est votre livre là qui s'appelle
trio on va en parler alors je rappelle
d'abord l'étude des ollies précédent et
la [ __ ] de la république donc
effectivement opération bravo un roman
déjà un premier roman qui s'appelait
relations publiques chez pauvert hélas
toujours chez pauvert donc un deuxième
roman qui s'appelle trio qui avait
commencé
à
ce qui se passe au corps alors le pitch
je suis le pitch le pitch c'est
l'argument comme on dit en bon français
alors halte en bobine ta vie on a
toujours embobiner incroyable fois que
les cinéphiles dans l'émission tout je
te dire que je suis tu t'es fait avoir
par des dirigeants cours tu font déjà la
tnt est revenue deux ans après on dira
tout ce que j'ai racontée c'était fou et
moi j'avais marché ouais vous avez un
pouvoir sur moi le conte annoncé après
roland dumas thierry ardisson s'est pas
encore des berluti non mais on ira tous
les deux à la carte de crédit donc c'est
une jeune femme qui s'appelle loup qui
est photographe et qui a vécu
douloureusement sa passion avec un chef
d'orchestre qui s'appelle sergei qui
était l'amant de sa mère alors elle s'en
est remis grâce à un ami journaliste qui
s'appelle david alors ils travaillent
tous les deux en tandem au tour du monde
lui il écrit des articles à elle fait
des photos et ce qui les réunit c'est la
musique
voilà la même passion pour la musique
classique mais le problème c'est que
david est homo voilà là ok vas chercher
tous et david tombe sous le charme de
dimitri qui est un jeune pianiste
virtuose mais là ya pas de problème
qu'est ce qu'ils font un trio et oui
vous savez jules et jim savait depuis
quatre ans j'ai écrit 4 3 livres un peu
contrainte parce que c'était des livres
aux pour pour me battre pour sauver ma
peau et là c'est un livre que j'avais
créé en 95 que j'ai ressorti que j'ai
terminé début 2001 et puis c'est quelque
chose qui parle de la vraie vie c'est
quelque chose qui me fait un peu comme
comment vous dire je suis un peu comme
une mouette qu'on a sorti du mazout ans
et plus étaient en vie
nettoyer mais plus ces gens c'est bien
dit ça tu apprends total en otage pour
se démarquer
elle est maligne
donc alors
décrire les choses que j'aime c'est ma
vie que la moto le sait l'amitié c'est
ça me change un peu de tout le monde
c'est par là depuis quatre ans elle est
très bien évidemment moi en lisant j'ai
cherché un peu des correspondants certes
tout le monde a cherché des
correspondants aussi je peux maintenant
tu te caresser aussi en visant plus bas
trio sergei si sergei j'ai adoré comment
vous pouvez dire ça mais je déconne bien
sûr je crois qu'on peut dire des bêtises
malus achat d'un fixe si je devais dire
les bouquins d'où les repris de justice
abc souvent les meilleures souvent vous
avez vécu le jour dans le sens france
améliore sergei ce chef d'orchestre la
scam un homme de pouvoir qui a largué
l'héroïne loup l'héroïne du bouquin est
quand même bon on peut penser à roland
dumas c'est toujours trop coup et page
53 parle de son piano steinway qui a été
offert par roland dumas par sergei mais
non alors en plus ces autos compatissant
sans doute là parce qu'elle dit en
parlant quelqu'un je ne peux m'empêcher
de penser à cette vieille amie en plein
marasme judiciaire pensez à vous la non
en écrivant pensé à vous c'est au projet
vous avez fait une carrière littéraire
nombre des conneries mais quoi non je
vais pas faire une carrière littéraire
j'en ai écrit trois pour me battre
j'écris suis là pour le plaisir et puis
c'est vrai que j'ai eu un avaloir qui me
permet de vous montrer une façon de
prochain pour l'instant j'ai pas de
prochain j'écris pour moi mais j'ai pas
de prochain en vue non parce qu'après
deux fléaux
on peut faire quatuor j'ai pensé non
le quatrième quart deuxièmement
christine deviers-joncour m messieurs
trier bien vous êtes et beaucoup de
choses par amour donc je vous faire une
interview par aman ans ne bouge pas
pendant le signal
[Musique]
je
voilà
ce soir
m
vous savez moi je vais bien vous faire
votre interne je veux bien tout ce que
vous voulez mais de débat williams et
depuis quatre ans c'est vraiment pas mon
souci quoi parce que tu es l'amour j'ai
suivi tous les princes galerie mais je
peux pas le croire il est pas depuis
quatre ans que j'ai d'autres choses à
attendre jusque là parce que depuis
quatre ans on parlait plus à roland des
mac vous vous avait pas de relation
amoureuse
je parle de deux gp chez lui d'autres
chats à fouetter
quant à me dire je vais pas me dire que
depuis quatre ans tu as vu des mondes
quand même vu des mondes qui parle père
roland dumas montagut roland garros 0,10
[Musique]
depuis quatre ans je fais peur avec tout
ce qui m'arrive parce que imaginez vous
un homme m'approche vous savez ce qu'il
risque depuis quatre ans alors des bons
pneus
quand way et finir avec
chers amis judiciaire les a non je suis
tapé sinon on va faire un test on va le
hanter
malgré l'effort de contrôle fiscal quand
on a rien fait décourager des graves toi
je pénétrai les emmerder mangerai
lendemain bush un peu rang bon alors moi
je comprends pas il ya des messieurs
pour moi qui rit ça va vite
ah oui ça va très vite est-ce que par un
mot vous seriez prête à quitter la
france oh oui bien sûr même pas sans
amour pour vous exiler au paraguay
n'importe où n'importe où est-ce que par
amour vous soyez prêtes à faire évader
roland dumas avec un hélicoptère
j'aurais pu le faire par à manger pour
lui j'ai fait ci presque six mois de
prison ont été nommés est-ce que par
amour vous accepteriez d'avoir recours à
la chirurgie esthétique par jeffrey
tournal pour moi maintenant de moi si
j'ai envie de me voir mieux dans une
égale peut-être un peu les nichons elles
sont bien une journal sont précis un
truc les peuples quant à lui à vous
laisser pas tallien formida peut-être
j'avais maintenu valide l'itie c'est une
des gogos garde de corti faut dire des
choses un talent y est elle est là mais
l'italien axa be
bon alors justement ça rejoint le votre
bouquin est ce que par un mot vous
seriez prête à vivre à trois avec sa
maîtresse
oui vous êtes formidables vaut vous
savez je trouve que finalement pourquoi
pas moi de toute façon les femmes me
disent wav je parle pas d'une façon
sexuelle mais je pense que les femmes
aujourd'hui sens pour moi un exemple de
déjà de courage lorsque les
satisfactions je parle de vie parce
qu'il ya pas que du sexe toute la
journée
d'accord d'accord donc j'aime j'aime la
compagnie des femmes depuis quatre ans
les seuls exemples de courage de truc
c'est les femmes
ah bah voilà vous voulez je suis dans un
bel exemple de courage oui j'ai envie de
le faire je peux oui eh bien j'ai une
avocate qui s'appelle sophie bottai qui
a eu le courage de prendre mon dossier
qu'est le courage pendant le procès de
risque et six mois de prison pour sortir
le dossier des frégates qu'elle a posé
sur le comptoir du comme on a dit au
tribunal
devant le juge elle risquait six mois de
prison et 7 femmes je sais ce soit qu'on
lui rende hommage thierry parce que
cette femme est en train d'essayer de
sortir de l'enfer
le petit michael blanc et je crois que
maintenant c'est logiquement je crois
que ce sera d'avoir une pensée
si elle est michaël blanc et voilà et
voilà
et
ouais mais voilà talia tient données
italien parce que christine de vous
connaître justement
oui merci rishton je pense que talia va
rester là absolument gagner pour rester
là vous êtes invitée permanente de
l'émission jusqu'au mois de juillet bien
alors est-ce que alors vous christophe
est ce que par amour
vous auriez accepté de vivre avec
l'amant de votre femme
quand on aime on ne compte pas en compte
à quoi bon comme tu vois je est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à aller tous
les samedis soir dans un club échangiste
non je crois
sa marraine du dessous de table dans un
club d'échangé on arrive maintenant une
question qui vient de clotilde courau et
c'est clotilde courau quittant
préventive
clotilde courau c'est une comédienne qui
quand elle était plus jeune
embrasser mille fois par amour les
chaussettes sales de son jules dépasse
pas non non vraiment bon c'est vrai les
gens aient un sens à peine de faire six
mois de présence et du japon c'est déjà
pas mal
des chaussettes sales en prison doit
revoir c'est vrai alors est-ce que
paramore vous seriez prête à prendre 20
kilos parce qu'il aime les rues basses
oui puis ça me ferait pas de mal j'en ai
perdu 13 en prison mais ça va très bien
oui même pas que par amour je le ferai
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
cacher le corps de la personne qui
devient de tuer je ne peux rien cassé
des corps saints sur les mêmes relations
parce que ce sont les deux choses les
plus importantes et je crois plus encore
l amitié quel amour et si un jour un ami
m'appelle dans la nuit mesure j'ai
encore j'y vais je l'aide
manquent pas ni pourquoi ni comment je
le fais c'est bien fait pour moi c'est
bien de voir les derniers comme vous
dites dans ouais mais beaucoup d'amis
comme ça mais dès qu'on du monde alors
est-ce que par un mot vous seriez prête
à faire du trafic influence pour couvrir
du trafic d'armes international
j'ai pas et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux